pop
[Musique]
le calme règne au katanga elisabeth
ville continue de vivre une vie sans
histoire au coeur de la sphère congolais
c'est dans cette atmosphère quotidienne
que le départ des dernières troupes
belges a réuni monsieur tomber le
général van horne commandant en chef des
forces de l'onu et une petite foule en
majorité européenne qui hésitaient entre
les vivats et les là
côte à côte le général gay scène et le
conte d'aspremont linden représentants
du gouvernement belge ont déposé une
couronne au pied du monument aux morts
adieu dont l'émotion a retenti au fond
de toutes les consciences belge
[Musique]
à
ce ne sont plus que les forces de l'onu
qui montent la garde dans les rues
d'elisabeth ville où monsieur tshombé
jouer avec assurance le rôle de chef
d'état que lui conteste monsieur lumumba
appuyé par son gouvernement
monsieur tshombe rejette catégoriquement
à la fois le congo unifiée et monsieur
lumumba
à léopoldville calme plat la ville
semble vide de sous les yeux des
patrouille et des sentinelles de l'onu
qui garde le bâtiment où l'état major de
monsieur h s'est installé après une
semaine de diatribes ou alterner les
reproches les réclamations et les
menaces le véhément monsieur patrice
lumumba semble s'être calmée sans céder
sur le fond et en maintenant ses
positions il a dans sa dernière
conférence de presse changé de ton
cela n'a pas empêché le conseil de
sécurité de confirmer implicitement la
mission de monsieur h
battus à l'onu monsieur lumumba va-t-il
chercher une revanche
on semble s'y attendre mais les forces
de l'onu compte maintenant plus de
quinze mille hommes au congo et elles
gardent tous les aérodromes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cour suprême soviétique siège dans la
grande salle des colonnes de la maison
des syndicats de moscou pour juger
francis gary powers le pilote de l'ue de
abattu en urss qui pète coupable général
borisoglebsky président de tribunal
l'accusation est soutenue par le
procureur général rodamco et la défense
de l'accusé est assurée par l'avocat
moscovite craignait la famille de powers
sa mère son père et son épouse assiste
au procès qui restera plutôt que celui
de l'homme celui de la maison blanche et
le procureur n'ayant pas requis le
maximum power s'est condamné à 10 ans de
privation de liberté
[Musique]
les championnats du monde de
parachutisme se déroule cette année en
bulgarie l'est de sofia sur le terrain
de mme oussatcheva
les juges ont arbitré trois épreuves
précision en groupe
les parachutistes sautent ans par équipe
de quatre de 2000 mètres d'altitude
style en chute libre et précision
individuel avec ouverture retardée
la france va se classer parmi les
meilleurs quatrièmes après la
tchécoslovaquie les usa et l'urss
le tchèque kaplan tombe presque au
centre de la cible et remporté l'épreuve
masculine de précision individuel
[Musique]
l'équipe féminine française se classe au
premier rang en remportant la médaille
d'or du saut de précision individuel
avec monique gallimard et en réalisant
d'excellentes performances en son groupe
est telle cette remarquable arrivé sur
la pointe de l'une de nos représentantes
qui ont fait monter les trois couleurs à
mme oussatcheva
[Applaudissements]
avec l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
rome déclenché une gigantesque opération
souvenirs à l'attention des spectateurs
et des milliers de touristes qui
séjournent dans la ville éternelle pour
l'occasion la louve romaine ne fait
place dans les vitrines à des myriades
d'articles frappé aux armes olympiques
tandis que les billets pour les jeux et
bié à l'horaire astucieusement précisé
se vendent par centaines de milliers et
que la police allégée par crainte des
embouteillages et sur les noms tout est
prévu à rome
y compris les meilleurs interprètes du
meilleur franchisé hp qu'un riche et
j'ai su par la france
du nouveau aux usa dans le domaine du
sport nautique compromis entre la cua
planer le hors bord les nouvelles
machines présentées à langast landes
sont doués entre autres qualités d'une
impressionnante maniabilité
[Musique]
festival de tentatives et de réussite
spatiale à l'ouest et à l'est le x-15
d'abord avion-fusée américain largué de
l'aide d'un v 50 de réussite à monter à
près de 45 1000 mètres d'altitude et ont
ramené ses extraordinaires images prises
par une caméra automatique
vécu un véritable homme de l'espace
alourdi par sa combinaison pressurisée
ces deux parachutes et ses instruments
le capitaine keating guerre américains
également s'élève en ballon jusqu'à
trente et un mille mètres d'altitude
pour sauter en parachute et n'ouvrir
celui-ci qu'après 26 km la distance de
paris à pontoise en chute libre
l'expérience avait pour but la mise au
point des équipements spatiaux et des
parachutes
car le retour à la terre est plus que
jamais à l'ordre du jour en
astronautique avec eco ballons géants de
plastique à lui misé retour d'entre
radiophonique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
placé au sommet d'une fusée tort belta
nouveau satellite américain mise en
orbite et roncq les servir de relais
radio pour les zones de très courtes
précis comme en écho largué dans
l'espace du cône de sa fusée porteuse a
été gonflé par l'explosion de 15 kilos
de poudre à 1600 km d'altitude une
cascade d'expérience coïncident avec la
réunion à stockholm du congrès
astronautique mondiale et apprend en
même temps deux autres succès américains
d'importance capitale celui de disques
horaires 13 d'abord dans la capsule
larguée après avoir fait dix sept fois
le tour de la terre est localisée au
radar est retrouvé au moment où elle
tombe dans les eaux du pacifique près
d'honolulu
[Musique]
celui de discovery 14 ensuite dans la
capsule après son voyage dans l'espace
et attrapée au vol par un avion cargo c
119 toujours large d'hawaï une véritable
prouesse pour le pilote de l'appareil
mais aussi la confirmation de la
technique du retour sur terre des
satellites les russes jusqu'à l'or
n'avait pas soufflé mot se contentant
d'enregistrer les succès américains
gardant pour la fin à leur public 5
ramené à terre avec les chiennes tlk et
strelka une voyons ici lors de leur
entraînement
un pas est franchi le voyage de l'homme
dans le cosmos est pour bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où est-elle aujourd'hui cette venise
secrète et romantique des esthètes
d'avant 14 et même d'un peu plus tard
aujourd'hui l'été ira même des foules
des peuples déconne touristes de tous
gabarits de tous poils de toute langue
avec leur débraillé bon enfant leur
désir de s'instruire et leur besoin de
voir ce qui doit être vu à venise car il
ya des traditions
[Musique]
tout cela ne va pas sans un certain
laisser aller on déjeune dans la cour du
palais des doges à pittoresque chasse
l'autre à tort sans doute mais le charme
de venise donne faim
du monde partout des foules partout
toutes les tailles et toutes les
élégances et tout ce monde caméra au
poing car venise est la ville où l'on
impressionne le plus de pellicule
[Musique]
c'est fou lui n'arrête pas tout ce monde
va vient repart revient et recommence
encore car venise offre cette
particularité d'être une ville bâtie sur
l'eau ne voulons arrête pas de marché
c'est ce qui fait que le soir les
pauvres pied demande grâce cette venise
d'été c'est un championnat de marche et
une litanie aux pieds sensibles
[Musique]
maintenant tout cela change-t-il
vraiment venise on aimerait mieux une
venise débarrasser des pique niqueurs et
des pieds fatigués mais il y a toujours
une petite place solitaire autour d'une
église oublier à rio vide
même dans cette villa touristes venise
est toujours dans venise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]